dans un bon soir était à l'aise bonsoir
les termes nous sommes toujours en
compagnie d'henri guaino
le sophia aram
et nous accueillons la tragique et du
samedi 20 heures ce soir faiz mohammad
accompagné de son entraîneur xavier
parmentier bonsoir
enfin bon soir en 2008 tu fouilles et le
bangladesh ton pays natal pour échapper
aux persécutions du clan opposé à celui
de ton père est dans tes bagages il y
avait un échiquier quatre ans plus tard
toujours sans papiers et sans domicile
fixe qui est devenu champion de france
d'échecs tu peux donc participer aux
championnats d'europe et du monde le
problème c'est que son passeport c'est
impossible de voyager
tu nous racontera son histoire à 20
heures
[Musique]
tu as une revanche soir
[Applaudissements]
et très applaudie déjà avant que ça
commence
alors tu es né le 26 juillet 2000 à
dacca au bangladesh d'une deuxième d'une
famille de trois enfants oui je ne
grande serre et un petit frère est
surpris alors ton père était d'abord
pompiers et puis ensuite il a ouvert un
atelier de réparation de mobiles est
avec ton oncle en ta mère femme au foyer
s'occuper des enfants
alors ton père a une passion ce sont les
échecs et dès l'âge de 6 ans tu
commences à jouer aux échecs et six mois
plus tard tu participes déjà à ton
premier tournoi je permettrai 0
alors à l'âge de 7 ans tu gagnes en inde
un tournoi réservé aux moins de 20 ans
et le lendemain battu à la une du
journal local tu commence à devenir
quand même une petite star hp contre
malheureusement en 2008 c'est la ligue
awami qui remporte les élections au
bangladesh et ton père appartient au
clan rival le bnp ce que le plan qui est
au pouvoir jusqu'à vous
alors c'est un peu comme nous et que
sarkozy hollande
sauf que là bas c'est beaucoup plus
violent les awami ne voit pas ta
réussite d'un très bon oeil et ils sont
jaloux et menaces pompaire de s'en
prendre à toi de temps levées et alors
là bas qu'on est quand les enfants de
tournage sont enlevés très souvent il ya
des réseaux mafieux et ils sont envoyés
dans les émirats arabes où ils servent
de jockey pour les courses de chameaux
donc évidemment ton père est très
inquiet il prend ces menaces très au
sérieux et il décide donc de quitter le
bangladesh avec toi on était cachée dans
des villages où pendant que le préparer
alors tu as 8 ans à l'époque
vous prenez tous les deux un premier
avion vers l'inde et ensuite un deuxième
avion vers la hongrie alors pourquoi la
hongrie c'est parce que tous les
premiers samedis du mois il ya une
compétition qui évalue les joueurs
d'échecs et qui permet d'entrer dans le
classement international
d'échecs donc déjà toi tu fais 18 cents
alors que le champion est à 2600 ont
déjà des dés la première évaluation on
voit que tu as un don extrêmement
particulier tuba le champion du tournoi
dès la première fois eh oui si ça fait
mal hier
les battues si belle saison
alors là vous partez tous les deux à
paris avec ton père mais vous êtes
obligé de rendre aux pacers les faux
papiers qui nous ont permis de voyager
et vous vous retrouvez à paris tous les
deux avec ton père sans papiers et est
au début d'un été hébergé chez un de ses
amis et puis après on perd il a contacté
france gardasil alors parallèlement ton
père tu inscris un cercle d'échecs qui
s'appelle la tour blanche dans le 20e
arrondissement là où vous habitez à ce
moment là
la mise en beauté
on a tout le monde est tellement
impressionné par ses capacités hors du
commun fahim qu'on te conseille d'aller
dans un autre club qui s'appelle thomas
du bourgneuf à créteil où évoluent des
jeunes de très haut niveau il ya vient
de bagnes entraîneur c'est parti voilà
est là sinon il avait l'équipe était
john key ça fait partie du numéro
alors terre d'asile vous trouve une
place dans un foyer à côté à maisons
alfort
ce qui fait que à la fois tu t'entraînes
dans le club de xavier est à la fois
vous habitez pas loin
javier rebond soir s'est pas fait ancien
entraîneur de l'équipe de france
dispenser des cours dans ce club quel a
été votre impression quand vous avez vu
arriver fame la première fois il parlait
pas un mot de français et puis il a
indiqué la solution d'un problème comme
ça simplement en bougeant les doigts et
il avait trouvé beaucoup plus vite que
tous les enfants qui étaient là donc
j'ai pris rapidement qu'il était très
fort alors là les ducs à chansons
frontières tout scolarise et en quatre
mois tu as acquis à un niveau qui te
permet d'intégrer une scolarité normale
quatre mois j'ai appris la
7 4
alors ce qui est formidable c'est que
vous voulu donner gratuitement des cours
d'échecs deux fois par semaine et puis
quand il faut mettre la main à la poche
pour payer de métro les repas le
vêtement
l'inscription pour les tournois vous le
fait aussi oui mais il ya tout un réseau
de solidarité
je suis content qu'on parle des
banlieues autrement aujourd'hui il ya
tout un réseau de solidarité qui se met
en place des parents des joueurs
d'échecs
qu'il connaisse qui éventuellement lui
paye le tournoi ça qui est
extraordinaire dans l'histoire de fine
d'ailleurs si la solidarité des gens
c'est assez touchant les assistantes
sociales les jambes de l'éducation sans
frontière
moi j'ai une pensée par exemple pour son
directeur d'école un petit peu kaka vue
fahim
qui a vu le potentiel qui avait un
instant fend enfin effectivement des
progrès sont exponentielles et en
juillet 2010 donc t'as même pas 10 ans
tuba un maître d'échecs est incroyable
un enfant de 10 ans qui va mettre des
chèques c'est rising ça c'est le signe
des champions ouais voilà mais quelqu'un
qui faisait le mec a été battu 2 à 1
devant de la faillite alors ligoté -
koné réglages étaient là font les partis
bon mais à part ça la vie n'est pas rose
parce que vos demandes d'asile sont
refusés vous êtes obligés de quitter le
centre d'accueil de terre d'asile et ton
père et toi vous retrouver à la rue et
là vous êtes pris en charge par le 115
alors évidemment vous êtes baladés
d'hôtels en hôtels c'est presque tous
les quinze jours qu'on va un peu partout
dans le val de marne
ouais mais c'est difficile d'aller à
l'école tout en changeant d'hôtel sans
arrêt
oui parce que je sais pas où je serai
site web voilà tu es un petit peu
perturbé et une et que 7e au championnat
de france
touche à sa place vous avez des aussi
ferrières et c'était un peu déconcentré
ici là que ton père plante une toile de
tente au bord du lac de créteil
d'argent il y avait plus de place ouais
alors là c'est dur parce que ta première
vie de sdf parce que vous êtes vraiment
sdf il ya un orage il pleut beaucoup
plus dort par terre dans un sac de
couchage tu dors pas beaucoup cette
méningite à dernière parce qu'il fait la
pluie qui tombait dessus 7e tour y
voilà mais là aussi une chaîne de
solidarité se met en place pour vous
loger vous nourrir vous vêtir et payer
les inscriptions aux tournois rue
parents les parents du club qui ceux qui
se sont relayés donc point pour le
recevoir six mois après avoir retrouvé
une certaine forme de stabilité
tu deviens champion de france
alors bis xavier il s'est battu jusqu'au
bout c'est la marque des grands
champions ça oui bah c'est à dire que
ils avaient plus à prouver que les
autres sûrement beaucoup plus de gnac
fine ça a été difficile pour lui il
avait une mauvaise partie il cogite est
pas mal et puis après il est rentré dans
la partie s'est accroché et puis là il a
tiré la partie nul qui lui permettait
d'être champion
grâce à ce titre donc tu es qualifie
pour les championnats d'europe à prague
au mois d'août prochain et les
championnats du monde en slovénie en
novembre il sans papiers et non c'est
impossible de prendre un avion alors
françois fillon a décidé de faire
quelque chose c'est à dire qu'il a dit
on n'attendra pas le résultat des
présidentielles on va commencer un
processus de régularisation c'est à dire
donner une carte de séjour à son père
faire en sorte qu'ils soient dans une
situation plus stable et qu'ils puissent
représenter la france bah oui voilà les
pays qui pisse peut-être aussi prendre
l'avion pour aller voir sa mère au
bangladesh parce que ta mère et les
frères ça fait un moment qu il n'a pas
vu sa c 4 ans
bientôt quatre états des nouvelles vous
téléphonez un peu
mais elle sait pas vraiment ce que tu
fais en france je crois parce que
veiller à d'un des journaux c'est normal
un site
super fier
je crois
[Musique]
alors
ton rêve en fait tu dis j'aimerais bien
être un grand maître d'échecs voilà ça
c'est ton ambition mon avis oui ça c'est
un peu comme en rêvent et ben quand je
serai combat j'espère convaincre ceux
qui tombent modèle aux échecs
par exemple les kin un joueur d'attaqué
moi j'aime bien attaquer ouais nous
sommes chez nous
mais toi aussi tu es un génie
mais aussi
[Applaudissements]
les errements de prese milan très
émouvant et voir comment les gens l'ont
l'ont aidé la battre et à lier toutes
ses formes dame je pense qu'on aurait pu
s'occuper de lui plutôt et mieux voilà
c'est fait moi je suis impressionné par
son niveau de français il est
hallucinant traitement il a pris très
vite et puis et puis moi j'ai hâte que
sa maman a pu sur voir voilà et ses
frères et soeurs aussi c'est vraiment
elle
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus